[Music]
what if the rolls were reversed prong
collars are painful and dangerous is
that puppy girl jenna yeah with the
redhead on a leash yeah i don't know why
i specified redhead that that already
took it up a level on the horny yeah it
really did with the sexy ginger yeah
yeah yeah what is with this image with
the hot ass ginger your dog wouldn't do
this to you don't do it my dog would for
sure do that yeah yeah that for sure
terrible logic if any dog had any chance
to put us put us on a leash yeah they'd
make that [ __ ] as painful as possible
yeah pp pp go pp yeah yeah yeah people
go go go party how's the [ __ ] field
dog go pee go pee do you have to party
you don't have to pee go party go party
that's what i tell my dog you can't pee
right now can you it's not ready yet is
it yeah go go go do it do it or you
can't go back inside hurry up i have to
go watch tv piss and [ __ ] both in one
session go right now go go i'm watching
i'm watching you wanna go for a walk no
i'm tired wake up it's 5 a.m we're going
on an airplane does that sound like fun
flying with ollie has been been funny
he's either doesn't care or is get me
the [ __ ] out right now you fly with him
in like a little carrier bag yeah and
does he like fight to get out of it
sometimes no he'll just wake him in the
middle of the flight and start punching
the ceiling a little bit i felt so bad
for chili we brought him like
brought him back from montana when we
were there for christmas and yeah it was
like we give him a little bit of cbd so
he's like sort of relaxed but then
sometimes he like kind of
you know he'll like just like
i don't know spazz out of it green out
no no we don't give him real weed what
is that image is just what is that it's
a remake of the image your dog wouldn't
do this to you and it's a furry it's a
sexy ass furry damn and the pants are
falling down what's with the person i
don't understand what's going on you see
you see how horny this image is it got
cody off of his point like immediately
yeah he was like that dog is ripped no
go back to the furry one so why does the
person have like dog hands
because it's a furry it's like a furry
fursona thing i wouldn't i wouldn't know
i have no idea what a fursona is persona
i don't i don't know what that is yeah i
have no idea
no bro i got a tangent real quick a dude
i know from like way back in the day he
got on a messaging app and it popped up
in my phone and this messaging app um
furries use it okay and so it's like you
know it says his name has joined the
messaging app and his profile picture is
a furry now it escaped me for months
this dude has just been kind of like at
the bottom
of my list okay and randomly i was like
it was that
so i scroll all the way down i look and
sure enough it's a furry image then i go
to his profile it is like
he's fully on there being a furry no way
yeah does he know that when he
downloaded the app all of his contacts
got that notification i don't think so
and the the profile description it's
like his whatever his like nickname is
you know i don't even know the gender of
the fursona you know he's trying to be
mean can you pull it up i mean yeah i
don't want to read it out you got to
read it out dude nah it's the bonus come
on this is what this is for no no he's a
good kid no no don't worry about the
name or anything just read the bio i
can't cause it it's like a call out to
his
person
can i read it yeah okay you can read the
beginning part
go ahead
it says yes
it is
don't don't you gotta stop there it is i
oh yeah the next part you gotta the one
and only and then it's his name now it
would be even better the [ __ ] furry
is sick though yeah it's ripped it's
ripped and has wings it's a fox and it
has wings should we should i text him
what's up yeah please on
on everything i love whoa we gotta blur
that
sorry what's a furry greeting that we
could use with him right now i could
just send him this are you searching
furry greetings right now furries have
read it oh yes oh is there any better
sentence than that i got a better one
from there any better ways to start a
sentence furries have read it anything
else that tr that
proceeds is gonna be amazing how do you
agree oh my what varnius kingston
australian links at your service bows
that's how this person agree i usually
say hello that's boring yeah what are we
even dressing up for at that point let
me see your face you are the you are the
one from my dreams then the stars at
night and
this is the day gods give me strength
okay
relax assuming we're in person if it's a
fur i already know i'll almost always
greet them with a big hug
at a convention
every fur gets a hug get first suitors
get an audible warning but they still
get hugs too i don't i don't even you
know i don't think just cause you're
furry i don't think you can just like
there it is impose yourself on people
that's the best one running up screaming
if pounce though is there not something
psychologically like inherently
psychologically demeaning about that
like i want to be a
domesticated animal i don't even know if
we can begin to yeah i don't think we
know enough psychologically analyzed
yeah i'll take it back
i'm sorry
please don't please don't message me on
your [ __ ] you know star fox
it's all taken care of on star fox yeah
your service yeah and be like hey
yeah what's that one right there oh my
god he's here he's so cute
this is a meme of all the goth girls
that know all the trap songs liking the
dog
from the pita image i got a better
sentence from reddit that i read the
other night that is by far the craziest
one i've seen in a minute i 29 male
sucked five dicks at a glory hole
parentheses i'm not gay
let's go